Je suis prêt mais vous devez vous étirer
car vous détestez ma maladie et je veux le
contrôler mais bon qu'est-ce que c'est que le tribunal a
dit oui oui mais qu'a dit le
médecin je ne me sens pas si en colère tout le temps
j'espère que vous  d'accord, nous sommes la soeur Annika qui
arrive Tiffany et Tommy juste
Tiffany ce qui est arrivé à Tommy
il est mort Holly est morte s'il vous plaît n'en
parlez pas hey Tiffany c'est Pat tu as l'air bien
merci je vais Tommy dime Oh quels
médicaments prends-tu je  Avant, j'étais sous lithium et
Seroquel était sous xanax, tu dirais qu'il
s'accrochait quantique et Patrick n'est pas ce que
je suis fatigué.
moi qu'est-ce que tu veux ailleurs
calme-toi fou peut-être qu'elle a juste besoin d'une
nageoire
tu veux dîner dans ce restaurant
viens me chercher à 7h30
je fais ton travail je viens de me faire virer en
fait oh vraiment comment salut avoir des relations sexuelles
avec tout le monde  au bureau tout le monde
j'étais très déprimé après la mort de Tommy nous
n'avons pas à en parler merci ho  w beaucoup
étaient là eh bien elle est un maître va faire
attention elle fait beaucoup de thérapie je vais
à beaucoup de thérapie suis-je foiré je
dois juste avoir une stratégie tu me connais
aussi
donc il y a ce truc de danse je ne peux le
faire que si je  avoir un partenaire je ne vais pas
danser avec toi alors est-ce que c'est la fille dont tu as
écrit sur toi a écrit sur moi elle est amusante
c'est mon amie avec un F majuscule
qu'est-ce que tu es tellement excité à propos de je suis heureux
regarde je suis mon meilleur  moi aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'elle est la meilleure d'elle-même et c'est une bonne
chose
que non tu ne veuilles pas écouter toute
notre vie présente un moment comme celui-
ci c'est un péché si tu ne reviens pas
c'est ce que je crois être vrai  vous devez
faire tout ce que vous pouvez et si vous restez
positif, vous avez une chance d'avoir un bon côté
vous